[Music]  kpop star t.o.p is recovering after a  suspected drug overdose the 29 year old  rapper is a member of BIGBANG  one of the world's biggest boy bands  t.o.p was reportedly found unconscious  on Tuesday the singer's medical team  told the Korea Herald he was suspected  to overdose on a range of prescription  tranquilizers which he used to treat  anxiety doctors tell the publication  quote he is still not breathing properly  and is recovering  we are currently attempting to treat him  but he's in an unresponsive state  shortly before the hospitalization t.o.p  was transferred from a police station  where he was performing mandatory  military service as a policeman after he  was rumored to have smoked marijuana the  drug is illegal in South Korea at the  time the Korean rapper said in a  statement quote I'll regret this for  tens of thousands of years  you  [Music]